social media helped her escape from the
abuse at home
for safety reasons where this name and
identity have been changed
the worst abuse was from my father it
was sexual and physical he touched my
body he kept me at home did not want me
to go out to school i'm 19 years old now
and when he started the abuse i was only
12 my mother and sisters escaped to this
shelter
a network of independently run shelters
has provided help to 1200 iraqi women
since 2003.
as a domestic abuse victim herself
janata rezzi who runs the organization
says government's failure to pass laws
to protect women gives immunity to
perpetrators
government shelters put impossible terms
for a woman who seek refuge there is no
strategy to offer help it took eight
years to take the law to parliament but
they failed to approve it there is a law
which prevent harsh punishment for
killings based on honor another
legislation gives the husband the right
to beat his wife under the pretext of
discipline statistics are impossible to
get most cases happen in rural areas
some are buried quietly some pressure
women to commit suicide or they just
burn her and claim she committed suicide
some report women missing and after some
time we discover she was killed
thousands of women are buried in
unmarked graves across iraq and
activists say many of them are victims
of domestic violence
with no official numbers rights workers
estimate at least one woman is killed
every week because of domestic issues
across iraq tribal traditions societal
pressures and families prestige all
contribute to making it difficult to
talk about violence against women
muhammad has to conceal his identity for
these reasons
his sister was murdered in front of her
children by her husband
for months there were problems he broke
her leg once another time her arm once
tried to burn her my sister didn't
listen and wanted to stay for her kids
then one day he shot her it's a pity
that the case is still in the court
three years later no one can explain why
the children witnessed it and neighbors
testified as well
lawyers like shohan say having clothes
is of no use unless they are implemented
there should be a special criminal court
to end this it takes a long time to
solve cases of women killed related to
honor my suggestion is to disarm people
and create awareness about these
killings
officials in iraq's kurdish region say
they're taking initiatives like this
hotline for domestic violence victims
and a special female police unit
last year we recorded 3 200 complaints
and some were of domestic violence
5 out of 10 women who were killed were
due to family problems
and unless the taboo is lifted from
violence emanating from those so-called
family problems
more women will continue to be buried
here
osama bin laden
northern iraq